in the 1920s and up through the 1950s
hollywood had a particular way of
talking come around about noon tomorrow
what are you doing up there
impersonating a book cover really really
it was called the mid-atlantic or
trans-atlantic accent but we don't speak
like that anymore so what happened
to know why it disappeared we need a
little history
the accent is sort of a british american
hybrid
linguistically speaking it has three
main tenets
one drop the r like mother and father
two emphasize the t like raita and
winter
and three soften your vowels like dons
and kaw
and this accent was acquired so there's
no line tracing it back through history
some believe it came out of early radio
when bass tones were difficult to hear
but many attributed popularity to writer
edith skinner she actually wrote a book
called speak with distinction which was
the book to help you learn the accent
either way it was a language for the
american upper class people like fdr
catherine hepburn cary grant they all
used it but after world war ii the
accent dwindled in popularity
with a growing middle class an
aristocratic accent was no longer
fashionable as for hollywood
acting methods changed and the accent
was just too fake
so it disappeared
mostly
if you've ever seen the show frasier
niles and frazier spoke with an updated
mid-atlantic accent to let the woman i
love die before your eyes that's right i
said i love her
lovely